hey what's up y'all Kelly Clarkson
hanging out with EADS he at the Critics
Choice Awards yes from powerhouse
fashionistas laying the red carpet it's
so much fun
two memorable speeches people who are
poor and innocent are behind bars while
the rich and guilty walk free and gain
power PT is taking a look at the
highlights from the 20/20 Critics Choice
Awards Joaquin Phoenix won Best Actor
for Joker and unlike his head scratching
speech from the Golden Globes the actor
went sweet and thanked his mom you never
gave up on me and always believed in me
and I'm deeply appreciative of your
support Alex Borstein won Best
Supporting Actress for her role in
marvelous mrs. Mazal and in her usual
fashion brought the funny this is a huge
honor but not a huge surprise what do
you hope this storyline of season 4 is I
hope the storyline of season 4 is that
sterling K Brown sticks around and Susie
and him run off together
manager to manager you know right why
not
I like we met at work yeah I think it
would be a beautiful love story Ava
Duvernay got a standing O when she
finally won Fest limited series for when
they see us thank you to the critics for
finally let us take a stage Eddie Murphy
who has been in the game for almost 40
years was honored with a Lifetime
Achievement trophy to make your living
making people laugh as there's no higher
pitch you're the luckiest person on
earth to be able to do that that's the
one thing when young actors come up to
me on the street and they say do you
have any advice for say never play a
spaceship while Kristen Bell received
the fourth annual see her award I'd like
to start by thanking first the critics
for just dedicating an award
specifically to outstanding women I
think that's very cool to me the idea of
womanhood is someone who sheds the
perfect little box and owns their
complexity the Kelly Clarkson
hilariously for young girls on stage
while presenting Best Actor in a comedy
series I personally love Eugene Levy I
love you so I just want to say that
shits Creek is the jam and Phoebe Waller
Bridge accepted the Best Comedy Series
award for fleabag and reveal Jennifer
Lopez was her character's inspo favorite
song Jenny from the blog and it opened
the entire character up for me but the
final award of the night went to you
once upon a time in Hollywood for Best
Picture and it's safe to say Julia
butters delivered the cutest speech of
the night we're very lucky and hello all
right
[Music]